[Music]
mackenzie is in austin texas hi mckenzie
how are you
hi dave i'm doing great hi george as
well i'm very honored and nervous to
talk to you both so go easy on me
how can we help
so my husband and i are celebrating our
one year anniversary today
yes very exciting thank you um but in
this last year we haven't fully been on
the same page as far as debt payoff
different mentalities so we did what we
both understood with our money and put
it in a savings account
because of that we have 130 000 in
savings and the unfortunate thing is our
student loan amount is our only debt and
combined it is almost 340 000
he is a chiropractor so the majority of
that is from him and what i know you
know about chiropractors is they only
really make um good money whenever they
open their own office so that's what
we're looking to do
but to do that it's a good chunk of
money for all of the equipment including
x-rays outputting the office to be able
to handle the extra unit all of those
things and so
what um part of what we're concerned
about is should we take our own personal
money to open up office to prevent going
into
further debt with a business loan but
also how do we protect our liability and
assets as well as we are also in a
transition where i'm losing my job at
the end of the year and would be looking
for a career change so it's not
necessarily stable so we're just kind of
this weird place where we don't
necessarily know what to do with this
money now that he's a little bit more on
board with paying off debt but all these
transitions make him nervous
[Music]
so what's he make what do you make this
year as a chiropractor
um he makes 70 now i makes us 60 and we
both are a real estate team and we made
around 50 to 60 for the years opens us
around 200 for the year
you did what with real estate what
oh we are a real estate team and so we
we're going to make around 60 000 doing
that part time
70 by himself
yes he made 70 as a chiropractor you all
made 60 doing real estate and you made
60. 60 in addition to that
so
uh
190 000 did i do that right
yes
okay and you guys are how old
um i'm 28 he's 31. okay
all right and how long have you all been
listening to this show
i've been a long time listener um he's
very new we just finished fpu which has
really gotten him on board with that
payoff
okay
well i don't think right now is the time
to to start a business i'm going to be
honest i mean you guys have done well
with your savings but you've got a pile
of debt to clean up here and the good
news is you have a huge shovel and so if
i'm you guys this debt is going to be
gone in three years
i'm gonna throw so much money at this
thing clear and clear out the savings
other than your three to six months
emergency fund and you guys got to be on
the baby steps and get rid of this thing
before we go start our own practice okay
our system didn't change
all that has changed in the equation is
that
now he has seen our system
that you knew ahead of time and our
system is of course avoid debt
and pay cash for things as you go
and you knew that
right i know that yes yeah and so the
chances of me telling you to open a
chiropractic office and go in debt to do
it
are zero
i would never do that
ever
under any services what about using our
own money i wouldn't do it until you get
the debt paid off because you can be
debt free in three years you just got
married you've been married a whole year
you have time and you've already put 130
000 away
already
so i would use the same energy to just
finish up the debt and then save up the
money to open the chiropractic office
with cash
okay so from not like pivoting from
there with me losing my job and changing
career fields um
how do we approach our savings account
so it wouldn't want to necessarily for
all of that to protect ourselves with
that well listen you make 60 and 70. you
made 130 000 without you having a job
right
right
okay i think you can probably get by
he said sarcastically
okay
well you could struggle through on 130
while you look for a job so set aside a
standard emergency fund you got 130 000
in savings
okay
okay so let's
you're calling to ask what we would do
if i woke up in your shoes where i want
you to be is to own a debt-free
chiropractic office and be making 200
000 a year on that and i want you to
have your career blossoming and be
making another 200 000 when you're 30.
how old are you now
28. okay well when you're 34 then okay
it's going to take you a couple years to
do all of this right
and that's where i want you to be but
between now and then what you're doing
will feel foolish to idiots in the world
and idiots in the chiropractic world in
particular
because they're all about how much debt
they can go in and there's this endless
pool of debt because they have this
endless desire to go and do something
that they're not yet ready to do and i
work with them all the time broke
chiropractors are everywhere
they're everywhere
and because they pay so much for a
degree that is not a medical degree and
they don't earn the income of a medical
doctor
and uh right wrong or indifferent that's
the realities economically and so
seventy thousand to a hundred thousand
is a chiropractor unless they own their
own office and then they get their
income up to 200 doing doing the stuff
but otherwise you're making less than
that and you paid as much as you would
have paid to get an md to get the
chiropractic degree and so that's the
that's the world you all live in and so
in other words his contemporaries or
what his contemporaries or peer group
does is not a good indicator of wise
you follow me
yeah he definitely wouldn't redo it if
he could go backwards yeah
but we're there now i'm not picking on
you for there i'm just my point is that
the group that is uh that you don't do
it the way the group he knows does it
that's a bad idea the way you do it is
you pay cash for the opening the office
after you knock out this debt so i would
put 30 000 aside as my emergency fund
i'd throw 100 at the 300 now i got 200
to go let's be done with that in about
two more years a year and a half or two
two two and a half two to three years
you're 100 debt free then you throw
another 100 grand aside and open his
office and you will open it with
different equipment than if you did with
borrowed money and you can make a good
living and you can reinvest back into it
as you go and grow your equipment list
and grow your office and even grow other
chiropractors working for him and begin
to build a sizable practice layer upon
layer
cumulative effect of this and you're
going to be in really good shape but you
need to be the tortoise and not the hair
you cannot
borrow your way into prosperity in this
setting you're going to create yourself
a mess and you already knew that i'm
just saying out loud what you already
knew mackenzie so i'm giving you
permission to be you
you already knew all this and the thing
is this is a four-year journey and that
might not be exciting as hey in three
months we could go start our own
practice but the problem is you're still
going to be broke because now you're
going to go into debt for the practice
have 340 000 in student loans and no
income is going to feel like enough and
it changes how you manage the practice
and it changes the equipment you buy
because it's all done with borrowed
money and under stress and it sets you
up for failure it sets you up for a
longer term to become
uh
financially free as a result of all this
work so you can make a really good
living as a chiropractor but you've got
to do it smart and you've got to do it a
different way than most of them do it
and sounds like you got a knack for real
estate between the two of you too
so um i can push on that button for sure
and then continue to work your other
career mackenzie
be patient
you've been married one
whole year
you've got time
you got time
you're gonna be okay
do it smart and do it gradual and do it
slow please